bonjour bonjour nous sommes en 2005
je vis à strasbourg heureux avec ma
femme véronique et nos trois enfants
j'exerce déjà depuis près de 20 ans un
travail singulier je suis psychiatre
dans un cabinet de médecine libérale à
strasbourg et je me suis consacré à
l'accueil des sans papiers je me suis
consacré à régulariser les étrangers
malades par la psychiatrie je suis dans
cette dans ce combat de manière un petit
peu isolé dans ma profession je m'épuise
je suis fatigué et mon épouse véronique
me propose de venir m'aider au cabinet
et de reprendre le secrétariat et le
téléphone comme elle l'avait fait jadis
véronique véronique mon épouse mon amour
véronique c'est une institutrice qui a
consacré quinze ans de sa vie à
l'éducation nationale personne n'est
parfait
quinze ans de sa vie jusqu'au moment de
prendre sa retraite après avoir conçu
trois enfants et véronique c'est comme
beaucoup de femmes quelqu'un qui a
plusieurs métiers dont tous ne sont pas
rémunérés véronique prend sa retraite
à ce moment là et va se consacrer elle
va se consacrer à un travail extrêmement
difficile aride
elle va devenir une des juristes de
référence à strasbourg dans le droit des
étrangers
elle va créer avec quelques amis une
permanence d'accueil des sans papiers
qui va vivre pendant sept ans à la
maison des associations tout proche
d'ici on travaille de concert
j'ai à l'époque 50 ans je les fais pas
un
j'ai 50 ans véronique un petit peu plus
je voulais éviter le détournement de
mineure
un petit peu plus et nous avions décidé
à ce moment là de vieillir ensemble nous
avions aussi pris le parti véronique et
moi de redistribuer de redistribuer la
moitié de nos biens à la collectivité
d'une manière ou d'une autre arrive le
15 novembre 2005
c'était hier à mardi
je suis pas près d'oublier cette date et
ce mardi je rentre le matin la fleur au
fusil qui j'ose dire à la maison pour
partager le repas que véronique avait
préparé avec créativité pour toute la
famille sauf notre fils david
notre cadet qui était installée à paris
depuis quelques mois elle revient
véronique au cabinet qu'elle n'avait pas
vue depuis sept ans elle revient dans
l'après midi elle s'installe mais elle
trouve ses marques tout de suite au
téléphone à l'accueil avec les patients
et patientes et puis à 16h40
à 16h40 elle vient me poser une question
elle me demande la confirmation d'une
prescription médicamenteuse pour une
pharmacie
et comme d'habitude je peux pas
m'empêcher de plaisanter elle repart et
ce sera pour toujours
nos dernières paroles échangées
16h40 leur l'horloge est gravé dans mon
esprit imprégné comme en relief un coup
de tonnerre éclate comme un gros plombs
pas un peu cheap l'ombre un gros plombs
j'ai un mouvement de recul un homme fait
irruption dans le cabinet je le
reconnais il a l'air extrêmement à
ferrer il est très motivé on a la
pression d'une mission supérieure qu'il
a à remplir
il tire sur moi deux fois j'esquive
encore une fois nathalie qui est la
patiente en face de moi en ce moment se
lève et s'oppose à l'agresseur vous
n'avez pas vue depuis cinq ans c'est un
homme qu'on avait soigné avec véronique
et qui n'était pas réapparu depuis cinq
ans il est là je n'ai comme recours que
de tenter de me sauver par la fenêtre je
donne un coup des pôles dans la fenêtre
on est au rez de chaussée heureusement
et là comme dans un film muet et comique
de
harold lloyd j'ai la résistance de la
vitre souple élastique très bonne
qualité je reviens dans le cabinet et
j'ai une deuxième chance j'ouvre la
poignée de la fenêtre
je me demande comment je suis encore
debout je passe par la fenêtre je cours
je fais dit pas ni lentement ni
rapidement je ne sais plus comment je
les fais deux détonations résonnent
encore j'ai mal dans le dos j'ai une
petite gêne je suis surpris de tenir
debout je suis surpris que mes jambes et
mes mains et mon cerveau répondent
encore à ses ordres
je vais me réfugier derrière une voiture
de l'autre côté de la rue l'agresseur
sort du cabinet ne regards se croisent
nous regardent se croiser il va partir
dans la direction opposée il va
disparaître au bout de la rue et
j'apprendrai un petit peu plus tard
qu'il est allé essayé de tuer un
collègue généralistes
de l'autre côté de strasbourg je reviens
au cabinet il ya du monde des patients
des voisins qui sont accourus véronique
véronique mon amour est allongé sur le
sol inconsciente dans une mare de sang
la tête touché je vais m'agenouiller à
ses côtés je vais la réanimer jusqu'au
bout une patiente une voisine plutôt
juive prie avec ferveur pour l'élévation
de son dame
et pendant ce temps d'autres personnes
appellent les secours et je réanime
verrou le réanimateur arrive je le
reconnais je reconnais tout le monde
dans cette pièce tragique et je me dis
que peut-être par sa science
peut-être par sa connaissance il va
suspendre momentanément le diagnostic
tragique peut-être qu'il va faire
balancer véronique du côté de la vie je
me dis ça quelques quelques instants
évidemment c'est pas le cas il me fait
comprendre que véronique est perdu pour
cette vie
et je m'effondre contre le mur véronique
va être déclarée morte le lendemain ce
sera le 16 novembre 2005
arrangeur du matin elle sera
hospitalisée dans un hôpital de
strasbourg là où elle a donné naissance
à deux de nos trois enfants et moi je
serai dans un autre hôpital
momentanément inconscient nous serons
donc séparé cette dernière nuit
je vais apprendre que nos gosses dont
david qui revenu de nuit la pluie
battante de paris on accepter le
prélèvement de quatre organes chez
véronique j'apprends aussi que david mon
cadet notre cadet qui s'est joint à un
rassemblement spontané le 17 novembre le
lendemain de la mort de véro devant mon
cabinet les volets fermés évidemment aux
bougies va transmettre aux amis aux
témoins présents il va transmettre ma
volonté que l'on puisse d'emblée prendre
en compte pour ceux qui le peuvent
la tristesse et la détresse de la
famille de l'agresseur va commencer
alors une période insupportable qui
n'est toujours pas terminé une période
insupportable qui va être marquée par
les réminiscences de l'histoire avec
véronique mon amour
insupportable le fait d'entendre la
sonnerie de l'école qui est au bas
d'immeuble chaque heure peut pas
l'arrêter
elle résonne chaque heure et après la
sonnerie encore plus grave les cris de
joie des enfants
la vitalité la vie qui se poursuit alors
que moi je suis mort insupportable
strasbourg cartes aux guerres
cartographier dans ma tête je vois
véronique partout partout où elle a
investi des lieux ça s'imprègne dans ma
tête
la carte est fixé dans ma tête et
j'arrive pas à la décoller le plus
déconcertant c'est peut-être du côté de
l'insupportable fait que pour survivre
je suis obligé de m'éloigner de mes
gosses mes trois gosses qui sont jeunes
adultes ou jeunes majeurs me rappelle
véronique à tout moment et c'est
insupportable
et donc je vais pour survivre m'éloigner
2 et donc négoce je me suis rendu compte
de ça après vont perdre un
la mère et le père ils auront la grâce
ces trois-là d'accepter de me perdre
pour me permettre de me reconstruire
dès que c'est possible je vais retourner
au cabinet des clés il autorités
judiciaires le permettent je vais aller
récupérer des dossiers de sans-papiers
cinquantaine de dossiers de sans papiers
dans un gros sac bleu et vous ne pouvez
pas imaginer combien un dossier de sans
papiers peut être vos luminaires et des
papiers partout avec en page de garde la
photo de l'usagé qui sourient pas mais
dont le regard s'impose à moi et
m'oblige
comme le dirait emmanuel levinas et
m'oblige à transmettre ces dossiers à
quelques camarades qui sont prêts à
prendre le relais le temps de mon retour
pour pouvoir obtenir un titre de séjour
d'un an pour pour ces personnes et pour
pouvoir leur redonner de la dignité
on va être amené à repeindre le cabinet
en blanc on va être appelé un ciré le
parquet à extraire le sens de véronique
a essayé de se débarrasser de l'odeur du
sort qui imprègne le sol on va être
amené à à combler le plâtre dans les
murs qui a explosé du fait des impacts
de balles
je j'ai toujours exercé la la
psychiatrie de manière originale et
inédite j'ai toujours cherché à échapper
à ce qui est convenu
j'aurais très bien pu accueillir des
patients de ma classe sociale qui payent
le dépassement des patients qui
demandent des patients dont je comprends
la demande
je me suis toujours intéressé je ne sais
pas pourquoi encore aux gens qui étaient
en marche
je me suis intéressé aux sans papiers
aux naufragés de la terre de la mer aux
sans domicile fixe aux mineurs isolés
je me suis intéressé aussi aux malgré
nous à ce que moi j'ai appelé les juifs
d'aujourd'hui à ce que j'invite à porter
le yunnan route le chapeau juifs du
moyen-âge qui stigmatisait les juifs au
moyen âge chez nous et qui en même temps
leurs frais une place j'ai toujours
essayé d'accueillir ces genres de
manière inconditionnelle et de leur
signifier qu'ils étaient les bienvenues
chez moi chez nous dans mon cabinet qui
est une propriété du sage
mon cabinet est à vous c'est vous qui
l'avez payé et ce cabinet est ouvert la
population générale sans rendez vous
parce que la plupart de ces gens sont
insomniaques et donc donner un
rendez-vous le matin à une partie de
cette population
c'est une faute professionnelle s'agit
de travailler à leur heure
tant que c'est nécessaire la mort la
mort
j'aurais pu pour essayer de lutter
contre les effets de la mort j'aurais pu
demander vengeance réparation j'aurais
pu demander l'application de la loi du
talion
j'aurais pu demander l'application de la
peine de mort je me suis rendu compte et
c'était vital qu'il s'agissait de ne pas
dépenser une énergie dévastatrice a
demandé cette réparation
je me suis rendu compte que si j'étais
tomber dans ce travers là je serai mort
je me suis rendu compte qu'il fallait
que je maintienne l'agresseur dans le
chant collectif de l'humanité et que si
il devait lui-même mourir un jour
il est droit à une sépulture chez lui à
strasbourg
j'ai toujours accueilli les gens s'en
sort rendez vous sur le mode de
l'hospitalité inconditionnel et je
continue et j'ai continué à ce moment là
et puis il ya ma deuxième femme suisse
j'ai choisi volontairement en tant que
juif ma deuxième femme magnard est
apparu sur mon lit d'hôpital
elle a forcé la porte de ma chambre
d'hôpital comme journaliste est apparu
comme une apparition elle elle est venue
m'imposer les mains prendre dans ses
mains mais main blessée elle s'est tue
elle m'a fait comprendre que je devais
continuer à vivre elle a accepté surtout
la présence en moi de véronique mon
amour et la présence de véronique entre
elle et moi
ania a pris le relais de l'espérance de
l'amour et je me suis rendu compte à ce
moment là il fallait absolument
continuer à travailler à l'hospitalité
et qu'il fallait lutter contre la
violence qui était en moi qu'il fallait
que j'intègre le fait que l'agresseur
faisait partie de l'humanité collective
et que mon histoire était un événement
mineur par rapport à l'histoire
collective et donc voilà c'est ça que je
vous apporte aujourd'hui que je vous
invite à méditer
alors quand je dis c'est ça ça fait
partie de ce que je vous transmets je
vous remercie d'être à l'écouté
ça me permet aussi deux d'élever vas
voir c'est ça que je souhaitais
soumettre à votre appréciation vous
donner pour pouvoir réfléchir ensemble
pour pouvoir aussi me convaincre d'une
autre voie possible
méditez sur le fait qu' on peut cultiver
ce credo cette espérance cette religion
pour moi travailler pour la paix par le
pardon
quand les hommes vivront d'amour
il n'y aura plus de misère
et comment seront les beaux jours mais
nous nous serons marc monfray
quand les hommes vivront d'amour
ce sera la paix sur la terre
les soldats seront troubadours
mais nous nous serons barbon frère
dans la grand chêne de la vie où il
fallait que nous passions où il fallait
que nous soyons nous sont comme profond
des filles d'accueillir toutes les
formes de la misère car c'est avant tout
notre affaire
euh pardon mais au diable les boucs
émissaires
de l'hospitalité soyons les
missionnaires
ou ensemble si vous voulez quand les
hommes vivront d'amour vous
il n'y aura plus de misère
heureux
et comment seront les beaux jours
mais nous nous serons encore là mes
frères et soeurs
merci merci de votre réseau
[Applaudissements]